so you want to be a landlord great
you're at the right spot but let me tell
you being a landlord isn't an easy job
like firefighting or being a governor
your landlord takes training and I'm
here to give you the training so you can
succeed and get the praise that you
deserve
when a new tenant is putting down their
deposit make sure they pay in a money
order never a check checks are too easy
money orders tiptoe the line between
ridiculous and inconvenient so they're
perfect now before your tenant moves in
make sure the apartment isn't at 100%
you know wobbly knob here a leaky faucet
there anything you can do to make sure
you get the security deposit or what we
like to call in the biz as free money
never answer a phone call from a tenant
whenever a tenant calls you they want
two things they either want you to fix
something or they want to tell you
something stupid like there was just a
burglary and you don't need that stress
in your life the only time you should
speak for the tenant on the phone is
when you call them up in 6:00 a.m. on a
Saturday to tell them hey into
Wednesdays from now I'm shutting off the
water for maintenance which brings me to
my next step every few months just shut
the water off for maintenance
what does maintenance mean I don't know
but the power of telling your tenant
when they can and can't shower is just
incredible so use that power you also
have the power of eviction every once in
a while not from the door and say hey
you've been a little loud lately or just
asking you have a look around
because this is your property you
control it own that power after your
tenant has been in the unit for about a
year hike the run up by two hundred
dollars just for funsies
it'll throw them off and confuse them so
you just did your job
if your tenant decides to leave your
unit for elsewhere make sure to inspect
that thing for every little possible
flaw you know a Wadley knob here a leaky
faucet there anything to secure that
free money because that's the end game
if you follow these steps I can
guarantee you will feel fulfilled
remember you are a landlord they expect
you to be annoying inconvenient and
mysterious